ela então muito bom dia a todos muito
obrigado pela vossa presença o tempo
escasseia e vamos então já a avançar
para uma prima do usuário e poemas leva
nos numa viagem no tempo até aos campos
de batalha da guerra da secessão norte
americana nos idos de 1863 uma foto a
última tirou salvando e para encontrar
um caminho esta imagem leio aqui porque
eu chego num editorial do new york times
de 20 de outubro do mesmo ano eles assim
acho tudo isto para mim o senhor ele não
estou seus cavalos mortos no campo de
batalha mas fez algo igualmente muito
impressionante multidões sobem as
escadas da sua galeria evolução sovisto
gráfica sinais do rio as carnificinas
obtidas indiretamente aspiração com o
auxílio do lupa do aumento os rostos dos
auxílios nos claramente distinguíveis
não está acusando nessa aula quando uma
mulher possa identificar na longa lista
daquelas na longa fila k nabas rosto do
irmão de um pai de um filho
estas foram efetivamente é a primeira
vez em que um grande público em é o
público em geral tomou contacto com
fotos de carnavais reais digamos assim
até então havia as representações da da
pintura clássica mas esta é a primeira
vez que viam há canais de pessoas que
viviam conosco enfim isto causou um
enorme impacto na sociedade da época
estamos eu uma das matrizes mais
populares da reportagem fotográfica
reportagem de guerra e extraí estimativa
de quebra coco no o clube mandou uma
equipa se toca que andava precisamente
num cenário de pressões é por muitos
considerado o pai do o pai do
fotojornalismo avançar próximos mas só
uma pequena queda histórica
essas fotos são 1860 já não é exatamente
da primeira infância na fotografia é
sempre mais difícil em 1826
mas até relativamente estável ou
problemas técnicos que dificultavam a
são do instantâneo a pressão da ação
isso levava é que portanto os temas mais
mais fotografados e até tem mais ou
menos esta época um pouco pois é uma
paisagem encontrados objetos de nerd
como carros no campo de batalha e o
então grupo usados como por exemplo aqui
nesta foto também também tem uma pequena
história por trás dela e isto é o
momento em que as linhas de ferro que
estavam sendo construídas nos estados
unidos uma por dia no oeste e outra
parte do oeste se encontrar um meio
caminho no um estado de utah no sítio
chamado montali point em 1810 1856
história quero que existe por trás desta
fiec e numa fontes documentais
andamos conta que os caminhos fernando
americanos foram construídos com o curso
é intensivo é uma numerosa mão de obra
da origem chinesa que trabalhava em
condições muito difíceis
vendo esta fotografia que é fotografia
digamos assim sua trajetória no momento
nós consegue derrubar o único chinesa na
fotografia
ou seja é como colocar o homem mas o
homem não está lá
o cruzamento dessas duas realidades diz
nos também do processo ou seja duas
horas do testemunho documental e desta
filosofia desde também ao seu assento
mais de sete anos na época
então é em portugal naturalmente tudo
fifa e ao seu caminho na documentação
dos acontecimentos sociais e políticos
como exemplo as encantadoras fotografia
do do algarve páginas web parts é um
próspero comerciante do povo
curiosamente o introdutor no cinema em
portugal e um fotógrafo amador
reconhecível republicano convicto que na
altura da implantação da república
amanhã a lisboa e e capitalista
encantadora fotografia de um ganho roso
civil miliciano
além do canhão boa a levantar agora
vamos capturá lo aqui na rua e isso não
deixa de ser irónico sobre nós
conquistamos bancos precisam que haja a
milicianos algumas apostas vão escolher
mais gosto dizendo que se passa lá
dentro do espaço hakka fora mas isso ia
frio quanto o do rosário
fazemos um pouco até a inglaterra após
vitoriana e temos aqui um instantâneo da
ação
mesmo tável este é o momento em que
surge esta é a medida isso é e invadiu a
pista da famosa corrida de cavalos do
derby em 1913 70 com as mãos nuas parar
o cavalo do sorraia eduardo sete em
queda quer ver na grã bretanha na altura
obviamente que a senhora foi
impulsionada por volta de uma espinha o
cavalo tem que ser ativa e enfim foi
toda uma comoção que muito calmo muito
trouxe muita muita muita atenção trouxe
para a causa sufragista atua na causa
dos direitos da mulher que é
extraordinário é pensarmos que há cem
anos a pouco mais de anos atrás não
temos para uma coisa assim um pouco com
o preço um pouco de ficção científica
mas falta a senhora e esta corajosa a
menina visando pagou com a convidada é
estreia esta esta espectacularização do
texto e é um instantâneo ação
absolutamente notável como certamente já
se aperceberam nesta altura já a questão
que eu falei antes da conquista da ação
estava resolvido em boa medida porque o
quem vê nesta conseguir nesta foto desta
30 numa trincheira francesas é da
primeira guerra mundial é impossível um
cão um caminho seja vou saltar por cima
dos soldados unicamente foi levado uma
mensagem é um outro chef francesa o
movimento quer ficar ou não a ter ficado
velho
a vida não deve ser levado uma bolada no
entanto numa destas aventuras mais
sólido tv todo o campo até porque sei
que é um artista só de ver neste
magnífico a fotografia do japão relativo
um fantástico fotógrafo um homem que
amava profundamente a vida e certa
maneira essa filosofia matriz para
centenas de milhões de instantâneos
felicidade familiar e todos nós temos e
que fazemos todos os anos que temos
nenhum nós somos em papel do nosso dólar
um dos nossos discos livros digitais
só então com este e com excelente
efetivamente mostra esta fotografia que
está em todos os ganhos da história é
uma coisa da história da fotografia e
justamente é uma fotografia documental
está americana mas levando quarta-feira
que fala possível é aquela imagem a
imagem vale por mil palavras aqui aplica
completa
vocês vejam bem acima da parte oposta da
linha fosse sobrinha está alinhada por
baixo os longas e as fotografias em
inglês sem gritar sem mais explicações
falamos tudo falando de utilização
social fala desigual a oportunidades
enfim vamos confiar totalmente
extraordinária e quinta possível
transmitir a sua mensagem por curso a
ironia é uma coisa que eu acho também é
muito interessante continuou tudo fiado
comentário às conclusões do século esta
é uma fotografia do rei foi o escoamento
pagã dísticos né na itália na itália
fascista 1938 uma criança ser
instrumentalizada claramente que faz
propaganda disciplinou não começou a
o político outra criança ainda durante a
segunda guerra mundial num ambiente
completamente diferente uma criança ser
socorrida por um soldado da paz no ano
de bombeiros bombeamento mães na no ano
de 1941 fomos estimulantes mas falta
dramática da segunda guerra vítimas das
sobreviventes de hiroshima documentos
terríveis e por contra a ponte preta é
esta se reúne às 9h e um bom livro ou o
bomba a ser apagada nos seus nos estados
unidos
os mestres absolutos nesta altura que se
convencionou chamar a primariedade do
fotojornalismo são o inevitável carteira
de som que instituiu o mantra do estado
civil que como no twitter uma foto no
campo vizinho ou não da cal no fim da
janela fechar libertado no fim da guerra
decadente da segunda guerra mundial em
roma antiga foi madonna vai gastar é um
cinema e trazia um primeiro contato com
a justiça militar e o inventário robert
capa e levou entre outras fotografias
pois transforma em um símbolo da nova
mania que tem aliás uma história uma
história curiosa porque por trás destas
imagens por isso estamos sempre vendo as
mesmas vamos te fiz o carro nesta manhã
conseguiu tirar três gols todos afiançou
708 108 difícil conseguir falar com ela
os custos roubos mas a pá no meio da
confusão da incitação do que se via
neste dia um técnico do laboratório teve
um passo em falso em sobre o que é ser
uma secagem de roupa e de onde ficavam
os motivos quase todos portanto dessa
108 difícil sobreviver até hoje às 11
são chamados magníficas nosso filho e
apostando sempre mais ou menos a perda
do filho do desembarque na normandia
isso aqui não precisa de apresentação
esta falta também do capanã na guerra
civil espanhola torna se um nível do
anti guerra avalia circunstâncias é
instante decisivo momento fatal é
preciso muita
é muito escuros acerca desta imagem e
fotografia assim continuou a fazer
documentário a aam o século folga
documentário os grandes acontecimentos é
o sima nixon no shopping e que é curioso
duas páginas do ilumina esta com o
assassinato do do jogo quem sabe a forma
não é absolutamente solidária está atrás
mas pronto é fogo é hoje a página já não
surgiam sempre difícil e passar cinco
anos uma forma muito mais impressionante
do outro canadense rob carnell de ser
assassinado também no momento de ser
assassinado e com agenda deus outra vez
não é essa no mesmo jornal em santos
estas duas imagens o conflito do vietnã
não foi dos mais documentados
fotograficamente é essa documentação
contribuiu muito também para a tomada de
consciência da opinião pública sempre no
bolso do fla passava de imagens de
plugar fitas como estas que certamente
muitos já viram e sempre não fez feio e
ganhar outras guerras um pouco mais o
clima zona e som é mais tranqüilo o alex
web na invasão do haiti em 1994 em
câncer ver que é uma coisa curiosa
portanto os malineses os marines
americanos acabado de desembarcar para
assumir a posição deste ano e eu lá em
cima uma bateria da escola de fotografia
infantil deus alguém fazer umas fotos
muito dramáticas e portanto isto é assim
uma coisa um pouquinho nos falamos
algumas cuidado entre o poder político
militar e mediático eo alex weber tem
muita gente lá três passos atrás e obter
esta foto do conjunto que efetivamente
começa por uma outra história
certamente que o do que os que nunca que
ela tem uns camaradas alistariam
estariam obteve muito casa esta foto
tirada por wilson na marinha grande e 86
com muitos dizem ter vôlei uma eleição à
presidência ao doutor suave e só este
fantástico instantânea do mestre longa
já no 25 de abril de 1974 em criou um
documento o momento
o em o salgueiro maia consegue convencer
as tropas que estavam hesitantes no na
no topo do centro é passar responsáveis
do dos votos assegurando assim o
controle militar em um tipo de situação
um dos pontos em comum um campo da
biologia paga pagar portagem fotográfica
tinha um prémio pulitzer do dokken lugar
nos jogos de barcelona 1992 pouco na sua
sua vez mais novas obtendo mais nova
emenda mais polêmica portanto aqui é
esta falta também sou bem acima da da
calçada uma 12 na madrugada em que pese
precisa ser testado nos jogos vídeo
desta ponte nesta nesta sexta-feira e
podiam estar aqui dentro ela velho
fotografias de momentos fatais nos
instantes decisivos prefeitamente não
sei até que ponto isto suplemento
disputadas nos contam muito muito muito
da nossa do nosso do da nossa vida e daí
que estão no nosso imaginário coletivo
baste mas há uma saída parece estar esta
jovem desta encantadora a fotografia do
autor português augusto santos silva
quando a moto com a parte final da minha
apresentação os momentos e por um
aumento de ontem a página está ganhando
do tejo col o tejo cão é um autor
escrita por intelectual e só está e
fotógrafo norte americano tem uma turma
muito incerto o futuro filho new york
times e clubes aqui embaixo vai
continuar assim mas eu gosto quando não
acontece ea tinha um sujeito de fãs
choram tauste funciona comenta eu
tamanho eu também gosto quando acontece
efetivamente gosta
este funcional é um dos introdutores da
andada correm fotografia enquanto a mais
valorização plástico e artístico e fazê
lo porque as cenas de uma grande banda
leela ou seja os alunos escolhem isola
momentos do do banal ou seja todos os
nossos momentos todas as nossas vidas e
99 por cento das ocasiões nós estamos em
situações também em lugares que
conhecemos como banais
o fato é que
esta olharmos com estas fotografias e e
e obrigamos a tomava uma atenção
adicional songa sobre estas imagens que
nos constroem ou seja é que o contexto
não vendável com texto sugerido e nós
somos nós que somos convidados ainda
fazer um com uma história uma fantasia
uma narrativa sendo que o que vemos isso
é muito interessante do meu ponto de
vista e foi isso convidamos agora
aconteceu esta fotografia
esta fotografia de um automóvel chamado
andreas gursky chamas ranjan em 21
segundos
segundo o correspondente a chegada em
1999 muito vocês olham com esta
filosofia podem pensar assim eu fazia
essa filosofia e também debaixo desta
sexta feira e é possível que eu nem
discuto isso o que eu digo é uma pena
que não tenham feito porque esta é a
filosofia foi vendido há meia dúzia de
anos que teria ligações milhões de anos
são essas portanto esta comida nos
mobilizando destas fotografias muito
apreciada no circuito no circuito
artístico mais de eventual aumento do
pessoal da reportagem por 12 fotos do
conceito mas em 29 de maio para a
aposentação e é muito certinho isso acho
difícil eu só vou dizer uma coisa dizer
é que efetivamente muitas delas têm uma
uma comunidade mobilizando o único papel
que eu vejo é que a coca cola foi uma
estranha se depois entranha e são formas
que o facto obrigam a refletir sobre
elas um pouco mais pouco o o o real não
está presente
da mesma maneira evidente que está está
em outro em outros momentos fotográficos
e nada acontece muita coisa aconteceu e
já vai mais brigar conselho estão
trabalho do vj vinagre chamas posto de
trabalho e isto são o volta do país a
fazer um levantamento fotográfico dos
sítios onde as prostitutas exercem a sua
o seu ofício
as prostitutas nas estradas mendes não o
fizerem distinto do dos outros filhos
yan uma outra forma de fazê lo a fazer
reportagem os intervenientes nação não
estão lá
mexe é é um tanto o contato estreito
sugerido através de pequenas pistas que
vamos ver vamos ver na imagem estava um
trabalho muito muito interessante do
ponto de vista muito valor e que
efetivamente se situam nos antípodas das
portagens clássicas que vimos na
primeira parte da apresentação
fascinante também essas duas construções
mas jamais o hotel em que os que mais
cometem punir smouha para uma uma
fantasia um mundo de fantasia em que se
constrói o real
o trabalho do americano ralph fiennes
tem uma série de 1970 chamados huambo e
aqui estendem à altura do filme não são
fotos digitais
a intervenção que o faz né no filme a
nível do grau da imagem do contraste
tenho uma casa eu tenho real à venda e
navegando sim pelo imã precisam das
peças a precisão da da expressão e do
facto convidado a mergulhar no mundo
onírico em que mais uma vez somos nós
temos que fazer a nossa ficção acerca
destas torres que nunca sabemos
exatamente o que estamos a ver o
português paulo nozolino adaptar uma
tática muito semelhante nas suas contas
são paulo em que a maneira como lula o
meio ambiente vai ganhar fisicamente
nestas imagens em que opõe os coletes
profundo que nas silhuetas da uma casa
desconstrói o real
tanto real é transformado numa outra
coisa uma coisa única de sonho e eu acho
isto tamanho fascinante o bônus lino tem
um lado lúcido reconhecimento nacional e
internacional e termina com as duas
fotos do de alguém que considera o
mestre absoluto nesta nesta nesta
vertente do joão momentos ligando assim
o japonesa e eu assim surge moto e aqui
uma imagem da sua série dos teatros
o que eu faço aqui eu aqui a globo toda
máquina no início da projeção do filme
só o faixa quando o filme acaba portanto
é que ela fique completamente branco o
filme está sendo injetado nenhum e todos
quer dizer é o filme que nós quisermos
projetar nossa cabeça
são fotos de fato são trabalhos
fotográficos vão para lá ainda
documentação do real e nesse projeto a
outras dimensões eu acho isto
muito muito interessante há aqui também
não então com uma uma vista uma imagem
das duas listas das vistas marítimas do
do estado o surgimento está uma visita
noturna domada e ao desacerto tabela
cada vez que vai filmar sinto uma calma
sensação de segurança como estivesse a
visitar a minha casa astral e em barraco
numa viagem de governo e pelo que foi
esta pequena viagem de ver que hoje
pouco tempo treinando aqui convosco
muito obrigado pela vossa atenção